you know one of the things that we used
to cover on the show regularly
before gay marriage was legalized
nationally were
all sorts of wild claims from religious
right people
about all of the terrible things that
they thought gay people were doing and
this ranged from
gay people or indoctrinating children
into being gay
children are being convinced to be gay
by gay people
to all sorts of things i don't even want
to say because i don't want this video
to be demonetized
this type of thing died down a little
bit when gay marriage was
legalized nationally and the anti-gay
focus shifted to so-called religious
freedom
but things are now coming full circle
and once again these wacky right-wing
politicians are getting into the same
sort of stuff again and this might be
one of the most ridiculous ones i've
seen
this happened yesterday this is an
interview with
newly minted trumpian republican
congresswoman lauren bobert
whose big um issue has been she wants to
carry guns on the floor of the house of
representatives she went on something
called the war room
and or real america's voice i don't even
fully understand what this is
and she stated i hope you're sitting
down
she stated that the equality act
currently uh being worked on
in congress is really a bill for gay and
lesbian supremacy
and she believes that it is being this
is her word
it is also being carried out by transvex
hikes
transvex hikes yes that's her word not
mine
take a listen to this we can't say the
same for the so-called equality act
which we all know uh that that's just
the democrats uh using a play on words
there's nothing about
equality in that act if anything um it's
it's the um it's
it's supremacy of uh of gays and and
lesbians and
and uh trans vet sykes i mean like
that's what this is about is about
putting them
higher than anyone else it's not about
equality trans vex
hikes that that is really something else
this is what happens when you elect
people who
know nothing stand for nothing
and bring nothing to the table but they
supported trump and that's why you voted
for them this is the this is what
happens
and i've talked but this applies to
marjorie taylor green
this applies to madison cothorn people
who basically run
social media uh offices they don't
run policy offices they run social media
offices and of course this is
embarrassing
it's homophobic it's disgusting it's
pathetic it's all of the different
things that we've known these folk
folks to be for a long time but
i'll take this as an opportunity to talk
a little bit about the equality act it's
not about
trans vex hike supremacy and of course
the word is transgender i want to be
clear that it's not just that she's
mispronouncing the word
the word we use is transgender but one
of the most important things
that this bill would do is it would
amend the 1964
civil rights act to explicitly prevent
discrimination based on sexual
orientation
and gender identity i've spoken before
since
gay marriage was legalized nationally in
uh by the supreme court decision
there are still many states in which you
can discriminate against people
based on their real or perceived sexual
orientation that is not banned federally
at this point in time
this act would ban it and that's
extraordinarily important
the equality act would also expand
protections for protected classes
beyond just employment and housing it
would cover any federally funded program
it would include
public accommodations which means retail
stores stadiums and other venues yes
this does relate to the anti-gay cake
baker
it would impact that sort of situation
and the playbook for opponents of the
equality act
is very predictable and we're seeing it
there with lauren bobert
it's assassination of character it's i
guess also creating new words
like transvex hikes but it's also saying
that the bill goes too far
it's saying the bill threatens
businesses
or people who might have legitimate
religious objections to serving lgbt
individuals in their businesses now the
bill does need 60 votes in the senate
it's unclear democrats can find 10
republicans to get this done
we know you know we talk about it's the
same conversation
maybe susan collins maybe lisa murkowski
mitt romney has already said he's not
going to vote in favor of this in the
senate
uh rob portman is unclear whether he has
any interest in voting for this in the
senate so
it looks much like the same old story
we're going to observe
and see but trust me this is not about
transvex hike supremacy that's the last
thing that this is about
and we'll have more coverage of this
bill and covet relief
and hr one on our instagram page find us
at davidpakmanshow on instagram
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
as well
one of our sponsors is sussman and han
sussman and han has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and
other supplies to stay safe during
covid19
and sussman and han is the company that
i've
personally been going to for face masks
and other ppe
because i trust the products that they
sell and that's actually why we reached
out to them about
becoming a sponsor because their prices
are reasonable
ordering is simple everything ships
within 24 hours and they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers
face shields sanitizers susmen and han
is also an awesome company because
they've donated over 65
000 masks so far to health care
institutions
shipping is free on orders over 150
dollars you can go to their website by
going to davidpakman.comask
the link is right underneath this video
and they'll give you twenty percent off
when you use the coupon code david